let's let's do something we rarely do on
this programme minister
and at five past seven in the morning
talk about football
uh for a change we're hearing from the
prime minister uh that in addition to
the semi-finals and the finals of the
euro this summer
he might be happy to host the entire
thing look is it
as a statement of where we might be uh
by the summer in terms of a return to
normality this is a pretty big one
well i'm not sure uh what the actual
details of this competition might be but
clearly the prime minister set out last
week
a strong roadmap uh many people i've
spoken to have been
uh very relieved of the fact that there
is a timeline i think it set clear dates
uh by which uh we want to reopen things
and obviously we want to get things
started the economy
up and running as quickly as possible
but as the business sector i'm sure two
things one you'd probably be happy for
football to come home any day of the
week
but if there's a possibility of england
hosting the world cup in 2030 that's
something you're going to be
at full square behind absolutely i mean
i remember
uh you know i'm old enough to remember
the european uh cup uh
96 i think it was uh and that was a
great case
we'd be very very happy to see a
significant football tournament coming
back
uh to britain but can we just
specifically though about this summer
you know we're
we're hearing rumors that perhaps
wembley could be properly rolled out
that
given where we are with testing given
where we are with vaccination
we could have 90 000 people in wembley
you know perhaps one of the one or two
of us
it could also be they're cheating on
whoever's lucky enough to get to the
final i mean
are we anticipating people being able to
travel
here uh look it's not it's march the
second 2nd
now i don't want to run ahead of
ourselves i think there's still a
serious
issue that we have with coronavirus
there are still people who are
very ill the vaccine rollout has been
very successful we're very happy about
that
but i don't want to get uh too far ahead
of ourselves
and speculate about wembley in two or
three months time
okay but just in terms of of perhaps you
know
the biggest news to emerge from uh the
new downing street news conference
yesterday the evidence
that frankly all of us were waiting to
hear that reduction in mortality and
hospitalizations
amongst those that have been most
vaccinated so far
given the fact that there is no
indication
that as we move through the groups
vaccine efficacy
will in any way drop we're expecting it
in fact to get better the younger
people get this is the beginning of the
end isn't it
finally we can actually say this is the
light at the end of the tunnel
i agree i think uh the the information
is very encouraging
and uh the vaccine rollout has been very
successful i don't want to
over egg the pudding though i don't want
to say that we're
completely free of coronavirus i think
there are still
dangers ahead but you're right the
numbers are encouraging
but i don't think it would be right for
me to to speculate about
football tournaments in three months
time indeed um just in terms of of where
we are in
in in combat in covet 19 in the united
kingdom can you provide us any update
as to whether or not we have we have
sourced that that sixth case
of the brazilian variant and indeed you
know have we had any indication from
surge testing in south gloucestershire
just yet
about any community transmission i think
we're still
uh monitoring uh the situation very
closely uh and you're quite right i
think there was one
case uh of the brazilian foreign as far
as i know there are six cases but
there's one
where uh the person uh involved didn't
uh fill in the forms correctly
and we're still trying to uh work out
exactly uh what's happened
uh to that uh potential carrier but
we're we're dealing with this situation
and i'd like to remind you also that we
have the south african
uh variants and we've been dealing with
that too but the vaccine rollout has
been extremely successful and as you
said earlier
it does give us a lot of calls for some
hope
um just in terms of of what we're going
to be hearing this week of course
tomorrow
budget day and as is common on this
program i'm sure you will not be drawn
into commenting on specific measures
which will be announced then i do think
though from a philosophical an
ideological standpoint i mean william
hague has said
look you know we have to be clear with
the public we have to level with the
public some business
some personal taxes will have to rise
now
away from the budget it certainly seems
like at some point
over the remainder of this parliament
that tax rises
in some form have to be a part
of the economic response to covert 19. i
think the main thing
uh certainly on my desk and certainly
the chances as well
it's a support business through this
very difficult time and you will know
that the
support that the prime the prime
minister and the chancellor in
particular have given to the economy is
unprecedented we've given something like
put in something like 285 billion pounds
uh since the corona virus pandemic
crisis began and i think uh in
tomorrow's budget the chancellor will be
very minded
uh to support uh struggling businesses
uh struggling uh people as well and so
that we can get through this very
difficult pandemic
as you say there have been huge amounts
of money
spent uh since the beginning of this
pandemic in terms of business support in
terms of support for individuals and
uh and so on however yesterday we
learned
that the government in in you know the
government in terms of its
foreign aid budget is not just halfing
it's cutting by by 54
the amount of money we give to yemen why
are we choosing this moment to do so
i don't think that um i haven't seen the
numbers but the actual amount
that we're reducing is something like
0.7
of gdp to 0.5 percent
and i think it was felt that uh given
the incredible stress
that we've gone through in britain
giving 0.7 of the of the economy uh
in this particular year was was
challenging i think the amount
has been reduced by little and after all
the european average is only
is 0.45 so we're still giving more of
our national wealth uh
i understand that eu country so i try to
answer your question but i think that
um i i i think that this is a temporary
measure i think the chancellor has said
that we want to
fulfill our commitments and we are doing
so
yeah it's a temporary measure at a time
when tens of millions of people
in yemen are at threat of death from uh
from from famine we gave 214 million
pounds
at yemen last year indeed beginning of
december we announced an additional 11
million pounds
at the foreign secretary telling the un
security council you know
new uk aid will save lives by making
sure the poorest yemenis can feed their
families
the uk cannot solve this crisis alone
other donors must now release their
funding
and contribute more support to prevent
this becoming an even bigger
tragedy that's the foreign secretary to
the security council calling on the
world to give more money
and then we announce that we're going to
cut it in half i think you would do that
anyway and i think
uh when you look at yemen and i've
traveled in the gulf a lot there's a lot
more
that countries in the gulf uh saudi
arabia and other countries
um can do to support
uh humanitarian crises uh in that region
before we cut our own aid budget we're
talking about
we're talking about lives here i know
the only thing i'm going to suggest is
you know the u.n secretary general and
others
are warning of a pending crisis in yemen
and we've just count the amount of money
that we're giving them by half
i think britain has always been at the
forefront of international aid responses
i think people in this country extremely
generous
uh the government has provided all sorts
of financial support
uh and also diplomatic support to crises
in the region
and we'll continue to do so as it's
often the case minister when when we
speak
at this time in the morning there is a
union flag over
your shoulder as there has been with
many colleagues clearly the union
has been more into the spotlight of in
recent times than perhaps it has been
for for a long time in terms of
at the conservative party at least since
the the last independence referendum
i just wonder if you agree with the
prime minister when he says that another
scottish
referendum is irrelevant uncalled for
and unnecessary i've always thought that
the
issue of scottish independence is
something for the people
in scotland i do remember uh in 2014 i
think it was that they said that the
referendum would settle
uh the issue for 25 years for a
generation uh and i am surprised at how
often
uh it's it's uh come back but it's up to
the scottish people to decide
uh when and whether they want to
referendum
do the struggles between alex salmond
and nicolas sturgeon perhaps make it
rather easier
for the government to resist calls for a
second independence referendum
particularly if as
as everyone expects the snp uh do rather
well
come the scottish parliamentary
elections in may well
i don't know how well uh any of these
parties are going to do clearly
there's been a lot of noise about what's
going on in the smp i think that's a
matter for them their internal
process their discipline i'm not going
to be drawn in on on the internal
politics
of the snp let's just see what happens
in the hollywood election in may